you can't show up on time you can't
practice you can't want to go out there
and win
you shouldn't be here because this is a
privilege it's the greatest job in the
world you get to go out and play a game
and if you can't care enough even in
week 17 even when you're
trash when you're four and 11 if you
can't care enough to go out there and
give everything you got and try your
hardest
impressive speech from j.j watt after
one of the many houston texans losses
in 2020 as expected
his final season with the houston texans
news that broke friday morning peter
just
after we wrapped up not long after that
first it was the pouncey twins retiring
and then they got to enjoy the spotlight
for i don't know 45 minutes
jj watt announces that he is out
in his sims off this week i tried to
explain to him last week all we do is
sit and talk about football it's not
like you need some time off but he
apparently needed a break from me so
peter you have to deal with me today
good morning how are you
[Laughter]
good morning mike you know when i saw
the wat news
last week i wrote my column
this would have been now eight days ago
i wrote my column that
you know just listening to uh some
chatter at the super bowl reading the
tea leaves
i thought that jj watt was going to
try to talk his way out of houston
and you know it turns out that
as i wrote that it was already happening
and on friday i really think what
happened here mike
and and as i wrote my column today i
think it's probably pretty
likely that nick casario the general
manager of the texans said whoa whoa
whoa whoa wait a minute we could
probably get something for this guy
even if he wants to pick out a few teams
that he'd get
agree to get traded to let's let's look
around now
that's just my educated guess i i don't
have that in stone but
nick casario's not married to j.j watt
and
uh you know but i do think that in the
end
intelligence prevailed you know j.j watt
has been fantastic for this franchise as
a player
and off the field and i just don't think
that they should have
held him hostage for the sake of getting
a
fourth or fifth round draft choice maybe
a third
well fantastic as a player a loyal
contributor to the team for a decade and
also
inching toward as you surmised
a potentially ugly effort to get
what he wanted we saw some tweets
recently we saw some support that he
expressed
for the equipment manager who was
unceremoniously dumped the latest in a
growing line of texans employees who are
now former texans employees and
i would suspect that he he made it
clear or maybe didn't have to make it
clear that if he didn't get what he
wanted he wasn't going to be as quiet
and discreet as deshaun watson has been
we'll talk about those two situations
coming up before we get to that though
here it's straight from the man himself
in the event that you didn't see it
on friday here's jj watt taking to
social media to let the world know
that his time in houston has come to an
end
i have sat down with the mcnair family
and i have asked them for my release
and we have mutually agreed to part ways
at this time
uh i came here 10 years ago as a kid
from wisconsin who'd never really been
to texas before
and now i can't imagine my life without
texas in it
the way that you guys have treated me
besides draft night i mean you guys boot
me on draft night
but uh every day after that you treated
me like family
and i truly feel like you're my family
um
since that day i have tried to do
everything in my
power to work and earn your respect
and try and make you proud on and off
the field i'm
excited and looking forward to a new
opportunity and i've been working
extremely hard
um but at the same time it is
it is always tough to move on and uh
i just want you guys to know that i love
you i appreciate you
i appreciate the mcnair family for
giving me uh drafting me and giving me
my first opportunity nfl
thank you houston i love you
and that was it and he said at 1.2 on
friday peter there would be no press
conference which
seemed a little bit unusual to me 10
years easy to set it up on zoom
get jj watt get cal mcnair
get nick casario get david culley maybe
even a little
little uh 15-minute warm-up routine from
jackie easterby some of his comedic
stylings to get things
going and none of that no press
conference and it just makes me wonder
what's the current mood between what in
the organization everything's
changed as far as he's concerned and
my guess would be and this is throw a
dart close your eyes and see if it hits
the board i don't think he wanted one
i think you're absolutely right mike you
know
when has jj watt shied away from
uh the media you know i mean
he's been one of those public guys in
the nfl over the last decade
um i you know mike look you were
the the king i i am a
distant 42nd to you when it comes to
looking at a video like that from jj
watt
and reading the underlying meaning
of his words and you know what my
underlying meaning was
reading listening to those words there's
not a lot a lot of love lost
right now between me and the texans it
just
there was no warm and fuzzy i owe
everything to this organization i
we have i talked to the mcnairs and we
have decided to part ways
i mean no i'd really like to thank them
i really you know whatever
it's like thanking the people of houston
i just
look i think jj watt is a very smart guy
he doesn't do anything unintentionally
why does he not want to have a press
conference why doesn't he not want to
talk to a bunch of the locals and i'm
sure he may eventually
i just thought the whole thing was was
odd as you say
and i suspect at this point in the
texans existence they
don't relish any additional
opportunities to be grilled about
deshaun watson because
that was inevitable that would have come
up and that would have overshadowed
potentially
the j.j watt exit press conference not
that that was the prime factor but i
think for both sides if this is going to
be about desean watson and not jj
what's the point of doing it but let's
keep it about jj watt peter because you
said something
that intrigued me i read it early this
morning in your latest football morning
in america column which is available for
anyone who would like to see it at
profootballtalk.com we ask that you at
least wait until after the show though
we've got some business to do here you
can read it later or during a break
although there's a lot there so it may
take a couple of commercial breaks for
you to get through all of it
bless you jj watt and his contract one
year left 17.5 million dollars and as
you said nick casario
still right still new
brand new not on the job a month if a
month barely more than a month
this is an asset and and this is how
general managers think
of their teams it dehumanizes the
players
don't don't get that wrong but at the
same time these are chess pieces
and this is a piece that could have been
with cooperation if they had finessed it
and it would have potentially required a
better relationship
than the one that currently exists
between watt and the texans
he reduces his salary to a range that
would be
suitable to someone who would trade for
it you work it all out
you let him pick his destination you get
a sixth round pick a fifth round pick
you get something
you get something for this asset that
you have purchased
through a contract that still has a year
left on it you get nothing by cutting
him you don't get a compensatory draft
pick
that only happens when a player leaves
via free agency
you get nothing in return when you cut a
guy
and that's what surprised me that there
was no effort and if there was an effort
they kept it very quiet
and i suspect that casario would have
found a way to leak it to make it
look like you know he understands that
you try to get something for every guy
you have under contract even the guys
that you
don't plan to keep anyway but they
didn't even go down that path and
i my guess is number one the mcnair
family thought that they owed it to jj
watt
to to let him go if he wanted to go at
this point in his career
number two agreed what probably wasn't
going to cooperate with that because all
he had to say is no
i'm not doing it no i'm not reducing my
salary
either try to trade 17.5 million
or cut me come march 17. mike
i i think first of all the mcnair family
uh janice mcnair the uh
widow of the late uh bob mcnair who
founded the franchise
and her son cal mcnair who is now
running the team
in essence i think they looked at
the contributions that jj watt had made
to
the city obviously the 41.6 million
dollars raised
in hurricane harvey relief it touched
every part of the city in harris county
uh it was an amazing job by what
uh in kind of summoning the best
in people around the world i think
that's number one and number two
this is the guy who's been the best
player in the history of the franchise
he wanted out and and quite honestly
mike there are some times
you say because look as i wrote my
column i talked
several people around the league and
asked what is j.j watt worth
most of them said nothing at 17 and a
half million a year after missing
32 games in the last five years due to
injury
and then last year playing the season
and getting and having five sacks
so you know he's not gonna bring much in
return if
anything but obviously he would have to
fix his contract
and i think that some of the contract
would have to be
incentive based and for a guy like j.j
watt who's the three-time
defensive player of the year and he
played 16 games last year i think he
really would have chafed at that
what's interesting now now that the 17.5
basically doesn't exist anymore
you know it it basically you can you can
make up whatever salary you want
i think this is going to be an
incentive-laden contract and j.j
watt is going to tell tom condon his
agent to essentially
here are the teams i want try to make
something happen
money's not that big a deal to me and oh
by the way
i'd really love to play for the packers
and and i i want to i want to get to
that in a minute because i have some
thoughts about
where he could land and some of the
practical complications that may go
along with
it when we think back to friday we saw
the j.j watt video
we saw the statement that was issued by
the houston texans
cal mcnair mobilized to speak to
as best i can tell a very small handful
of reporters
i noticed in your column today he spoke
to you he spoke to shefty he spoke to
ian rappaport
i didn't get invited to participate gee
i've i i can't say i'm stunned given
some of the opinions that we've crafted
over the past few months about mcnair
and more specifically his right-hand man
jack easterby
but what did you gather from the
conversation with mcnair and isn't it
odd that casario
didn't have anything to say to anyone
mike it was
uh he was very nice he said all the
right things about jj watt
was not going down the road to about
desean watson other than to say he is a
texan
and i expect that he will remain a texan
and uh what a great guy he's been for
this franchise in the city
basically i read the stuff that he said
to ian and adam on friday
and i'm not saying he was reading it
from a piece of paper but it was the
same same stuff
and look that's fine it's absolutely
fine
my only point about all of that is that
i agree with you i think that if jj watt
had not gotten his free release
had not gotten his freedom uh
i'm not saying it would have gotten ugly
but my opinion is that
there's a chance and a pretty good one
that what would have been outspoken in
saying that
what an organization this is in what is
supposed to be
you know a uh a family-driven nfl
that you know i helped raise 41 million
dollars in a time of dire need
for this city uh we've you know with me
playing here we've won four of the last
six
division championships i won three
defensive players of the year
i'm the best player in the history of
this franchise and you're holding me
hostage for a fifth or sixth round pick
that might be might rise to a fourth who
knows i
i don't even know what it would be but i
do know
that from taking the temperature of
people around the nfl
there was not going to be a lucrative
market for j.j watt
yeah well and especially not at that
salary and if you're going to be
negotiating a lower salary anyway just
do it as a free agent
and and i think that the texans who have
done many things in recent months that
could not be characterized
fairly and reasonably as smart did the
smart thing in not picking the fight
with jj watt it can be postured as them
doing the right
thing the right thing was to not make
themselves look even worse
by getting into a fight with jj watt
that they would and more importantly
locally at a time when the perception of
that team in houston is as low
as it's ever been since they joined the
nfl
19 years ago getting into a fight with
j.j watt would have made it even worse
and
he said something funny about cal mcnair
not funny like
like funny like a clown funny intriguing
i had a flashback
to the first time i ever heard cal
mcnair speak he did
radio in houston the flagship down there
610
and it was like he was reading off of a
sheet of paper
when when you said that about the
comparison of the comments to you and
shefty and ian it it when he was on
radio it
sounded like he was reading straight
from the talking points that someone
else had given
to him so here's a glimpse of the
talking points that made the rounds on
friday
said cal mcnair on jj watt and on the
biggest issue currently involving the
team desean watson it's not the right
time to talk about the front office it's
all about jj and honoring him
there is a lot of misinformation out
there i'll leave it at that
well you wouldn't want to take advantage
of an opportunity to clear up
misinformation would you today we want
to focus
on jj we don't want to focus we do want
to focus
today we want focus on jj sean is our
quarterback he's a texan
and we expect him to remain a texan and
we'll leave it at that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports